something super interesting is going on
in the wake of Fox News firing Tucker
Carlson as Fox struggles to find a
suitable replacement which we'll talk
about more a little bit later on in the
show as Fox continues to try to beat off
other lawsuits current and potentially
future related to Tucker Carlson's
programming and what's going on behind
what went on behind the scenes at his
show we have additional leaks that
reveal Tucker's displeasure to put it
very light likely lightly with elements
of Fox News this is a Media Matters
report Fox leaks Tucker Carlson slammed
Fox Nation in behind the scenes video
this uh article is by former David
Pacman show guest Matt Gertz not Matt
Gates often confused this is by Matt
Gertz and um it says Tucker Carlson
headline Fox news's Fox Nation streaming
service in the Years leading up to his
sudden firing but a behind the scenes
video obtained by Media Matters shows
him lashing out at Fox for the service's
unbelievable failings apparently while
doing some em at image rehab for
misogynistic social media influencer
Andrew Tate now I have to tell you we're
going to look at the clip here of what
Tucker had to say about Fox Nation it's
a pretty damn accurate criticism of Fox
Nation Fox Nation is the streaming
little brother or sister of Fox News the
network channel and uh let's listen to
what Tucker had to say it's very very
interesting I don't want to be a slave
to Fox Nation which I don't think that
many people watch anyway
um we're gonna uh because I I you know
I'm like a representative of the
American Media now right speaking to an
exile in Romania and welcoming him back
into the Brotherhood of journalists
okay so first of all this is just
endlessly funny apparently what they're
talking about is the you know the guy
Andrew Tate who was arrested for a while
and I don't even know what's going on
with him I don't follow Andrew Tate
Andrew Tate I guess normally wears suits
on interviews and it seems as though
they're trying to convince Tucker for
this Fox Nation thing to wear a sweater
so that he is equally casual to what
they're expecting Andrew Tate to wear I
think that's what I'm understanding here
and Tucker's just getting annoyed
I mean this is airing on the nighttime
show and I want it to look official I
don't want it to be like bro talk and I
and I
you know what I mean the majority of it
like if we go like 45 minutes
but nobody's gonna watch it on Fox
Nation nobody watches Fox Nation because
the site sucks
this is just the best that you know I
actually I I do not sympathize with
Tucker on almost anything but I've been
in situations where like you know I'll
have a direct affiliation with some
entity and then that entity has some
other affiliation and they end up making
requests for things they want me to do
like at a conference and I know that my
contacts are really just being bugged by
these other folks who I don't really
want to have anything to do with and
they make these requests and the the
frustration with Tucker about they're
trying to make me do stuff that's really
not good for me and it's not good for
anybody and nobody's gonna watch it
anyway
I really empathize with that
specifically beyond that you all know my
feelings about Tucker so I'd really like
to just put the dump the whole thing on
YouTube
um but anyway that's just my view
um
uh I'm just frustrated with uh in it's
hard to use that site I don't know why
they're not fixing it it's driving me
insane and they're like making like
Lifetime movies but they don't they
don't work on the infrastructure of the
site like what it's crazy and it drives
me crazy because it's like we're doing
all this extra work and no one can find
it it's unbelievable actually I don't
know who runs that site
[Music]
I know but we're doing our part we're
like working like animals to produce all
this content and the people in charge of
it whoever that guy's whatever his name
is like they're ignoring the fact that
the site doesn't work and it's I think
it's like a betrayal of our efforts
that's how I feel so I I think I've had
this exact phone call with people like
that this is the funniest thing this it
resonates so much with me now of course
what Tucker wants to be disseminating
instead of that is absolutely horrible
stuff the the real story here is not
Tucker's frustrations per se
it's that it appears as though this
stuff was leaked from people associated
with Fox News directly to Media Matters
and it is such a stunning turn of events
when Fox people Fox Affiliated people
are leaking things to the to the
left-wing Media Matters and we're going
to see what ultimately happens with the
fourth com with the existing and
forthcoming lawsuits against Fox News
and the role that Tucker Carlson has to
play there I actually had I I just
filmed a podcast episode with Lex
Friedman very long episode like almost
four hours long pretty wide as well
probably three hours wide if you can
believe it and it's going to be released
soon and we talk about the claimed
reasons that fox fire Tucker which have
to do with politics which are false and
the real reasons that fox fire Tucker
which have everything to do with legal
liability and the fact that he's become
a real problem uh this to me is just
funny and Tucker's criticisms of Fox
Nation are absolutely spot on I've even
been invited on Fox Nation and they go
yeah listen we Fox producer here we'd
like to have you on oh like which show
well it's like the Fox Nation after the
show like the bonus show equivalent but
it's like not award-winning the way ours
is
um and also there's like a guest host
this week so and I'm sorry guys I'm just
too busy I'm just too busy I've got a
you know a baby running around diapers
everywhere it's crazy I can't do it I'm
sorry I can't do it so that I very much
identify with all right now let's move
to
how is the search for Tucker Carlson's
replacement going